bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale la tv
pour la deuxième deuxième partie de ce
premier tour du championnat du monde ces
32e de finale du championnat du monde
féminin 2015 à sotchi en russie
donc on a vu dans la première partie les
françaises marie sebag et sophie millet
avec deux résultats opposés puisque
marie donc l'a emporté avec les noirs
tandis que sophie millet a perdu sa
première partie avec les noirs également
donc deuxième partie de ce match puisque
ce sont des matches en deux parties donc
avec tie-break éventuelle en cas
d'égalité
donc là on va voir la première partie de
ce deuxième match entre marie sebag et
young la chinoise marie domaine de
points est là les blancs donc il faut
bien avoir en tête 7
ce score cette situation de match si
marie ne perd pas la partie eh bien elle
est qualifiée donc nul
une partie nul suffit aux blancs pour
passer le tour et il faut que les noirs
gagne absolument s'ils veulent arriver
jusque au tie break
donc on va voir tout de suite comment
cette partie s'est déroulée partie donc
tendue puisque c'est la qualification
pour les seizièmes de finale qui se joue
sur cette seule partie
c'est parti e4 pour marie c'est 5 pour
wang yu
ces trois
cavalier m6 on est dans une s'il y est
bien fermée de type fermé
qu'on l'appelle à la pine 7 signal si
celle-là avec ses 3 l'idée c'est de
jouer eux 5 et des cartons qu'on évite
les schémas les schémas ouvert c'est une
autre façon de jouer une forme fermée
quasi fermé de la cécilienne e5
voilà c'est classique alors les blancs
auront leurs pions sur cases noires ce
qui fait que les cases blanches sont un
tout petit peu faible et donc les noirs
en profitent ils mettent leurs cavaliers
sur un des cinq des quatre qui comprend
très bien
on reprend pas tout de suite camille f3
bon mais on aurait pu reprendre tout de
suite mais là on peut jouer avec trois
sans problème puisque si les noirs
prennent en c3 avec le pion évidemment
la dame prendrait le câble et des cinq
donc mari choisit ses maris qui choisit
cette ouverture un tout petit peu fermé
bon le comprends si on tient compte de
ce qu'on a dit au début c'est à dire que
le match est à son avantage elle a gagné
la première avec les noirs donc une
nulle du suif hisser au noir de
démontrer qu'ils peuvent gagner et ça
sera peut-être d'autant plus difficile
dans ce type de variantes qui plus est
je peux dire que marie la connais très
bien pour pour l'avoir vu la jouer
plusieurs fois et notamment aux
championnats de france
rapide à nancy en 2015 ou moi même
d'ailleurs j'ai pu l'affronter sur cette
variante là et j'ai compris que je
savais pas la jouer voilà donc ces six
céfran des quatre des six voilà très
bien des six c'est logique 1 les noirs
commencent à mettre la pression sur le
centre blanc c'est aussi l'idée de ce
type de variantes si vous voulez c'est
vrai dans tous les cas c'est par exemple
le cas aussi pour la grüne fel et cérons
laisse les blancs occuper le centre
voilà plutôt que de leur contester
l'occupation on les laisse et pour
essayer de contre attaquer ce centre là
de mettre la pression au maximum sur le
centre blanc alors là on commence à le
faire et le cavaly c6 qui attaquent le
pion de 10 qui attaquent parfois on joue
un g6 fou g7 et on ajoute de la pression
voilà donc les blancs ont plus d espace
un centre mais c'est les noirs passent
leur temps à le harceler fous ces quatre
voies la c4 déjà un coup intéressant
mais sur j'attaque le câble et des 5
alors il ya plusieurs coupes haussier on
peut jouer au 6e 6 protège des 5 c'est
possible aussi
mais là les noirs choisi ce qu'avaient
les v6 pourquoi pas
marie connaît très bien cette variante
il joue faux b5 clouage voilà n'hésite
pas dans le foot est attaquée de toute
façon donc l'idée c'était de sortir ce
qu'avaient les dessins qui quand et bien
placés en des scènes c'est vrai il est
central bon on joue en fout des cinq
bessin oncle ou sky et non par exemple
si les noirs près dans le cinq on peut
prendre du cavalier en faisant pression
sur ses six donc qu' on prend 1,5
c'est ce que font exactement c'est la
suite de la partie et la foux dix-sept
chinois je vous fous 17 c'est quasiment
forcé il y avait deux pièces sur ses six
potentiellement
on peut jouer qu'à laisser trois des
cinq mois des choses comme ça donc il
faut faire attention on élimine le fou
maintenant voilà marie élimine le
défenseur alors on garde la paire de fou
puisqu'on a donc foulé sign fou fou
c'est un jeu ça a duré mais en tout cas
c'est le cas mais on a un pion isolé
voilà le pion des quatre est isolé voilà
alors il faut faire attention en finale
c'est pas un avantage d'avoir un pion
comme ça tout seul il n'est même pas
passé puisqu'il ya un pion eux qui
l'empêchera de toute façon d'avancer
donc si une cible potentielle mais on a
en échange la paire de fou dame prendre
17 des cavs a laissé trois menaces
attention tout de suite des 5 et
s'inquiète une menace puisque le calais
peut pas bouger puisque le fou ici
attention clou à la fois le cavalier et
puis même la dame sur sur leurs
intentions mais il ya beaucoup de choses
ce fou est magnifique
donc le le coup suivant des noirs est
quasiment forcé un mur c'est aussi ça on
empêche des 5 et en même temps il est
temps de sortir aussi le full auto et
suit donc c'est un coup logique aussi
petit rock très bien fawcett
on prépare aussi le roc dames g4 coup
logique voilà on maintenant que les
cavaliers le khalife 6 notamment est
passé un des cinq b6 bon ce côté là
c'est un peu faiblard sait il manque un
défenseur il manque le ko lip6 donc dame
g4 est un coup intéressant puisque 1 je
garde un oeil sur des 4 et j'attaque g7
donc parfois se fout il aime bien venir
en assises pour menacer matt bon
événement avec le fouet cette ya pas de
problème on peut jouer en rêve 6 mais
attention le cavaly c3 peut venir des
fois en quatre pour menacer à y avait
des attaques de maths bon voilà il ya
des choses attention à ce type de
variantes ou la dame des anges et 4 ça
peut très vite tourner au cauchemar un
petit rock tour d un voilà très joli
coup tranquille on a sorti la dame on la
remplace par la tour c'est toujours
désagréable d'avoir un vis-à-vis tour
d'avion parce que en cas des changes au
centre
on n'aime pas la dame aime pas avoir une
tour en face à elle préféré que ce soit
une dame pour s'échanger et voilà il
faut pas oublier que les noirs doivent
essayer de gagner
bon là pour l'instant bah c'est mal
parti c'est à dire que là c'est à dire
que là le bon la position leur donne pas
pour l'instant de possibilités d'actions
bon parfois il faut être faut être
patient alors les noirs jouer un coup
responsable un peu tendu mais pourquoi
pas f5
bon c'est chaud parce que c'est chaud ce
genre de coups parce que si c'est faible
maintenant voilà le si si en plus il est
sûr qu'à ce blanche et le fou de case
blanche n'a pas été éliminé bon vous me
direz la lecavalier b6 empêchent ils
contrôlent les casaques à ses cadets 5
pour se caler b6 et de l'or il contrôle
très bien des cases blanches donc bon de
ce côté là le pouls b5 semble pas trop
dangereux il est dominé par cavalli b6
mans mais ce pion aussi c'est sur une
colonne ici ou ou semi colonnes selon
l'appel semi colonnes plus tôt puisque
ce colonne ouverte c'est qu'en tire ou
qu'un pion quand y en a qu'un on dîne
semi colonne ouverte où une colonne semi
ouverte plus tôt donc le coup suivant de
maryse se comprend très bien dans me2
voilà on vient sur eux deux parce qu'on
fait pression sur six appareils tout à
fait tout à fait logique
alors là on pourrait se demander
d'ailleurs ici si un coup comme
comme ici que je fasse
voilà donc on peut se demander si un
coup ici comme qu'à aller prendre des
quatre ne marche pas ça c'est
intéressant puisque on se dit bon bain
et si les blancs prennent la dame 17
je prends la dame avec échec
je reprends le cavalier et j'ai gagné
une pièce parce que si cavani prend fou
tourcoing fou et en plus ce fou manas
fou prend ainsi donc ça marche pas voilà
donc il c'est simple donc ça marche pas
du tout donc dames 2 à 6 voilà à six
attaques
le fou mécène tout simplement la marie
est embêté puisque la le fou bombay s'il
s'en va c'est possible dans ce cas là à
d4 et peut être véritablement emprise
qui allait prendre des quatre a prêché
en plus je peux le protéger par et si je
peux le surprotéger par une autre tour
sachant qu'il n'y a pas de pions pour
l'attaqué
bon je risque de perdre quelque chose
donc les changes du fou contre cavalli
semble semble forcée et alors là marie
va faire regarder une passe d'armes au
plutôt que de prendre ce qu'elle aurait
pu faire directement
keller très intéressant essayons de
essayons de voir ici pareil je vais
faire
fou prend d'accord faux prince et six
sur pions prend ses 6 voilà c'est
possible qu'on prend c'est mieux voilà
jeu français adam prendre cet emprunt y
avait des cinq qui avait assez fort à
cause du fou et 7 qui étaient sous
l'emprise de la dame mais après puis on
prend évidemment une des scènes marque
lui voilà donc là ça a l'air bon pour
les noirs donc c'est pas tout cas c'est
pas mauvais donc à 6 donc c'est possible
quand même fou prend puis on prend bon
ça aurait laissé un pion c6 faible et un
pion aux six faible aussi bon mais le
plan des cas très faible ainsi donc
voilà ça fait des faiblesses partout
c'est possible mais il trouve une autre
solution encore peut-être plus plus
tendue puisqu'elle vous des cinq des
scènes c'est intéressant mais ça a l'air
de bons mais ça l'est ça laisse la prise
ans et 6 ans mécène pardon donc c'est ce
que font les noirs puis on prend les
cinq des princes et 6 et après d'un
processus il semblerait là que les noirs
ont gagné un pion puisque puis on
dessine qui a disparu mais le pion des
scènes qui lui-même étant prises
donc après il faut garder jusqu'à la fin
de la variante après cavaliers prend b5
bilan des courses bas il ya toujours
égalité deux pions puisqu'on a trois ici
deux ça fait 3 et de 5 et les noirs ont
4 et 1 5
bon qui plus est le pion ici c'est un
toujours un peu à la ramasse il est un
peu arriérés
il semblerait même que les blancs et la
meilleure structure de pions voilà donc
7 7 passes d'armes semble laisser un
petit avantage d'ouverture toujours aux
blancs en termes de structure de pions
mais y'a plus la paire de fou les deux
fonds qui avaient potentiellement tout à
l'heure on te suit disparu la position
s'est simplifié donc on se rapproche
d'une
du nul qui n'arrange pas les noirs je
vous rappelle que les noirs sont dominés
au score 1 donc il faut qu'il trouve une
moment il gagner tous rêvent des huit
chinois de cintra lis ces pièces qui ne
joue pas ça c'est bien
il a tranquillement faut être quatre
pour marie très jolie ont fini le
développement on lit les tours c'est
très bien tout reprend tout reprend
attention alors là ça laisse le pion à
deux reprises ça c'était étonnant alors
là que se passe-t-il si je n'ai pas fait
ça donc je vais trouver la solution plus
tard voilà donc ici
si les noirs prennent en a deux c'est
une possibilité
un très joli coup du blanc qui vous dit
qu'il nous ramène à la partie d'ailleurs
et c'est très joli regard des fous des
six magnifiques
pourquoi ces attaques le fou aux 700 on
est d'accord
facile à comprendre et si les noirs
prennent le dis on a misé le fou peut
prendre
oui alors si les noirs prennent et bien
il ya derrière d'hommes prosys avec
échec
voyez avec une attaque de maths
il ya une attaque de maths en plus ça
qu'il faut comprendre parce que où va le
roi et après on va faire cavalier prend
et où si laurent un fluide sa menace
après calais prend au regard d abord on
va faire la variante tout simplement fou
prend regarder dans prend échec suroît h
huit cavaliers sans doute prendre les
six voilà c'est fini
hop menace échec et c'est mort s'est on
peut dire que c'est mort d'autant plus
que je vous rappelle qu'il faut il faut
gagner la partie en plus ce ya au moins
nuls quoi parce que échec
roger huit cavaliers h 6 échecs roi à
suite cavalière cet échec car ils
agissent comme peut-être maths en plus
parce que là comment protéger voilà
imaginons que les noirs protège avec h6
ce qui est possible
regardez up il y avait aussi ça la dame
la tour est perdu voyez donc attention
marie connaît très bien cette variante à
la place et un joli piège pour prendre
tout reprend le pion à 2 était un pion
empoisonné voilà hélas les morts
peut-être s'en rendre compte ils se
disent mince donc qu'avaient les
desseigne pourquoi pas d'accord et là
regardez moi je pense que c'est une
préparation maison de notre championnat
de marie c'est une préparation tendu
delà de ce type de position très jolie
pareil fou des six mêmes idées même idée
un joueur food et 6 rebonds mais je
propose des échanges potentiel
je propose éventuellement de gagner un
fou et surtout je menace d'un point 6
échecs
si fou prend d'emprunt si c'est cher et
après je récupère des six soirées
lecavalier soi même
oui avec le câble et c'est bien ça
laisse une attaque sur le cavalier des
cinq attaqué par la dame par la tour et
en plus ce qu'elle ait des six menacera
pareil devenir f7 avec un échec et un
math possible ah tiens à noter aussi que
de ce type d'opposition
il peut y avoir le fameux maths à
l'étouffée alors me direz mais c'est
quoi le matin à l'étouffée ben justement
on va on va voir ça donc le matin à
l'étouffée c'est qu'on va faire une
variante simplement vous allez voir si
les noirs prennent en d6 simplement ont
fait regarder d'en prendre six échecs
dont paris rendront ensuite cavalier
prend fou et donc on a dit attention le
cavaly maintenant en plus et en menacent
donc il faut bouger le cavalier donc
imaginons qu'on mette le cavalier en f6
on est d'accord
le cal n est plus en prise regardez le
très joli matin à l'étouffée kalyev cet
échec avait huit cavaliers h six doubles
échecs dames + cavaliers très important
maintenant si l'euro à bien et suit
iliad 9 7 matches puisque le cavalier
protège à mauvaise nouvelle et si le roi
vient ensuite regardé la cocotte-minute
se referme d'un g8 échec protéger la
dame est protégé par le cavalier il faut
donc prendre cette dame soit avec le
cavalier soit avec la tour imaginons
qu'on prenne avec la tour est bien dans
les deux cas c'est la même chose
pouf bling matt est mis sous le roi est
enfermé par ses propres pièces c'est la
cocotte-minute
elle est fermée et les pommes de terre
sont prêtes
voyez que c'est chaud donc car il est
des cinq très joli coup food et 6 avec
cette menace de maths à l'étouffée
potentiel derrière c'est chaud donc ça
oblige quasiment voient leur rêve s'est
heureusement il ya une défense mais la
regarder très jolie marie je vous
damages 5 et a tout prévu échec par mais
on ne peut pas défendre échec avec et g6
parce que j'ai six d'un prophète et ça
devient une boucherie donc c'est pas
c'est pas envisageable a donc
il faut revenir manger vite je vous
rappelle que marie mendome points donc
c'est là qu'il faut avoir l'oeil parce
que dans me2 on revient aux deux à toi
c'est en gros si tu refais les mêmes
coups je répète la position et j'ai
gagné le match
alors la chinoise se répète une fois roy
f7 damage cinq échecs car il prend la
nuit évidemment et la lachinoise il faut
qu'elle fasse quelque chose parce que si
elle revient à angers vite je reviens à
eux deux enfin je rappelle l' arbitre je
pense qu'il faut appeler l'art mineur
avant d'avoir joué le coup et dire à
l'arbitraire des jeux je peux jouer dans
me2 ça répète trois fois la même
position
hélas l arbitre accorde la nul donc
trois fuites et la foux prendre cet
échec d'accord tant qu il l est l
échange ici tranquillement alors à noter
que le pion h7 est perdu éventuellement
ces shows on peut prendre soin du
cavalier soit du roi bon les noirs
choisissent du roi pourquoi pas c'est un
peu penser à peu près équivalent le
cavaliere aurait été possible aussi et
maintenant qu'il y ait des quatre ans la
très jolie
le câble est maintenant bien en d4
puisqu'il est plus protégé par la dame
qui était en jeu deux je vous rappelle
attaque adam b5
on voit que laurent noir est aux fraises
c'est à dire que la regarder dans les
courants d'air le roi blanc lui mais lui
il est très bien protégé il ya égalité
par ailleurs en termes de pièces mais en
termes positionnelle en plus les blancs
sont bien quand on sait qu'il suffit aux
blancs de faire nul on se dit c'est bon
pour marie quoi voilà on se dit là si on
est supporters ont dit c'est bon on va
penser à commencer à réfléchir au
prochain tour dames c'est cette dame
j'ai cinq échecs 3 et 7
et maintenant on regarde est très jolie
tranquillou faut tout calculer un mais
regardez la dame et ans et 7
ici la casse et un est protégé par la
dame g5
ça permet la manoeuvre regardez up car
l'épreuve 5 blum
menaces badham projet 7 ramasse tout
échec au roi il sans doute des maths
derrière des trucs
bon bref c'est l'horreur donc il faut
prendre le cavalier est là simplement
tout reprend tout reprend on peut pas
venir fermathe du couloir puisque la
dame et angers scène protesté seins donc
faut avoir le coeur bien accroché mais
n'y a pas de problème f5 et emprises
d'accord et j'aime tout au plus alors
qu'une nul suffit et le roi noir est aux
fraises et drake warner g6 d'amd de
centralisation est d'accord les blancs
ont centralisé leurs pièces ici plus
lourde
ils tiennent le centre qu il tienne la
colonne des menaces tour 17 et schengen
la dame de gagner la dame à noter que
tout reprend 1,2 marche pas parce que
tous riches et croire tout reprend dame
y'a pas de mal du coup leur suffit de
ramener la tour anciens donc là que fond
noir bondam c6 pourquoi pas mais en fait
c'est un peu faiblarde à 3
tranquillement consolide sa position
mais les blancs sont gagnants là on peut
dire un déjà tour c'est 8 g iii empêche
d définitivement tout mode du couloir
pour ses sept tours des six a tourné six
attaques la dame commence à avoir un
oeil sur la case m6 en aimant bien avant
une dame qui vient faire un petit échec
en abscisse sans doute gagnant dames 8
dames échec 3 g7
dam des quatre échecs rouages 6 et
maintenant mari prend là nul facilement
échec
on va les sept dames f6 échec 6 forcé
puisque maintenant regarder si sur la
machine les noirs jouent le roi sur le
g8 ou ensuite tourné huit et c'est fini
la dame icloud voilà donc fourrage 6 est
quasiment forcé h4 échec pour les sept
dames f6 échec pour la justice et c'est
fini la partie est terminée
probablement même les blancs on aurait
pu essayer de la gagner là on peut faire
d'un point f5 il ya les noirs menace
rien du tout dimpre en excellent je
gagne un pion de plus un échec de la
toon au nasria jouant g2a rien du tout
les noirs sont toujours aux fraises il
en être commence à avoir deux pions de
moins leroy toujours en menacent de se
faire mater en permanence les blancs
auraient pu gagner cette partie mais
bien sûr mari cherche pas à gagner la
partie mais cherche à gagner le match
elle en position extrêmement supérieur
et les propose nulle part répétition
tout simplement elle force la répétition
et elle le gagne donc ce match et elle
est qualifié en 16e de finale bravo
marie magnifique premier tour de marie
sebag qui qui est en forme à sotchi
alors on va voir maintenant la deuxième
partie qui nous intéresse aussi bien
entendu c'est sophie sophie millet donc
qui a perdu la première partie avec les
noirs mais maintenant cette fois elle
allait blanc est là les blancs donc elle
peut très bien arriver à revenir dans ce
match il suffirait de gagner cette
partie avec les blancs c'est toujours
faisable toujours envisageable et dans
ce cas là de se qualifier en jouant les
tie-breaks donc ici donc peu 4% fumier
qui joue un début ouvert e 6 des quatre
des cinq qu'avait laissé 3 6
aux cinq as lors de cinq attaques
lecavalier classiquement c'est connu
enfin call et 17 pourquoi pas f4 donc ça
c'est une défense française plus ou
moins classique alors les blancs centre
ici est pareil les noirs ici le contre
attaque avec le coup c'est simple la
base une débat dans l'ambiance et on a
une double chaîne de pions là puisqu'on
a des 4 5 et aussi f4 scène on attaque
la base des cartes on attaque le centre
surtout à la cascade l'équipe je vous
rappelle que ces quatre cases constitue
le centre
ces cinq ici protégé par le fou ces cinq
souffre ou se fout protéger point qu'à
vider cette attaque le centre assez
classique kf3 câble et 6,6 on rajoute de
la pression qui va très bien phu et
trois à six pourquoi pas donc à 6
empêche b des coups sur la case b5 on
empêche loubet cinq ans n'empêche qu'ils
allaient vaisselle et on peut aussi
jouer b5 avait décidé de jouer des 4 2
pour perturber les blancs mais sur ces
possibles aussi dam des deux la preuve b
donc c'est une position de temps d'une
position théorique compliqué puis on
prend donc choisi si on prend fous ces
cinq coups des trois
rien
alors j'étais en train de réfléchir food
et 3 alors qu'est ce qui se passe sur
qu'est ce qui se passe ici si on fait
plus
une regard d une petite variante ici si
on fait des 4 1 lors des 4 as l'air bien
puisque des quatre vidange attaques de
pièces alors tout à fait jouable
alors qu la vallée prend est possible
tout simplement cavaliers prend à huy et
donc l'idée c'est évidemment par exemple
de jouer simplement fou et 4 x 4 très
bien ce fou attaque la tour à 8 quand on
défend c'est tout roule à boujan n'y a
pas d'autres coups faut bouger la tour
puisque si on vous qui allez si on prend
et maintenant on peut reprendre en d4
puisque il n'y a pas de problème la dame
maintenant attaque voilà donc c'est
l'idée c'est que la torah 8 est sous la
menace du fou des 3 voilà donc fou
détroit n'y a pas de problème sur des
cats et une fausse menace donc la petit
rock et noir tombe pas dans le piège
d'un f2 alors d'un f2 ça ça propose ici
d'échangés se fout c5 sas à contrôler
aussi des quatre donc d4 est pas
possible d'un v6 donc là il faut prendre
ces cinq là les procès senc très
intéressant et la sous famille nous sort
une préparation maison tout à fait
intéressante
punchy regardez c'est classique dans ce
type de position aussi dans la française
ça arrive fréquemment surtout en blitz
je dirais mais en partie longue aussi ça
peut arriver la preuve le roi ici est
dénué de défenseurs à part les pions
voilà cercle cavalli et si ça a été un
parti c'est souvent le cas quand tu as
le pion à celle qui a été jouée le fou
des trois-visages 7 le cavalier peut
venir angers 5 et la dame peut venir sur
la colonne h classique je dirais ça pour
le joueur d'attac ça va être un réflexe
il faut envisager en font réfléchir à
chaque fois faut regarder mais faut
envisager la suite c'est à dire fou 37
sacrifice de fou alors là si les noirs
ne prennent pas jours à la suite d'un
match 4 et puis c'est non seulement j'ai
gagné un pion mais en plus la tacc de
maths
elle est gratuite en quelque sorte un
tir que les
les noirs n'ont même pas de pions mais
pas appris la pièce et vont se prendre
la même attaque donc il faut prendre le
fouille a pas le choix il faut que
c'était sacrifices et là d'un match 4
échecs ce qu'on voit et ça ça semble pas
très très bon au prince c'est à leur bon
quand même alors fou euro à prendre un
set à lors d'un mach 4 échec 6-6 bon si
ça son cavalier échec ou d'un match car
c'est bien d'un match 4 échecs que font
les noirs
roger 8,1 très bien et maintenant
corrigé 5 alors la différence en général
c'est que souvent la dame au lieu de
venir acheter être allé en d1 il vient
h5 l'aca menace maths en fait faut bien
voir ici c'est d'abord là une menace
demain déjà il n'y a pas le choix faut
bouger la tour
il n'ya pas d'autre quoi et quand la
dame et h56 la tour bouge on peut
prendre f7 d'abord le roi revient et
après on revient on va venir avec cette
ville en a éliminé le pion à vii c'est
pas la même parce que là dans cette
variante ici après tour est vite bondée
damage cet échec on peut pas faire dans
le premier set puisqu'on rh 4 évidemment
ça marche pas roy est fluide damache
huit échecs 3e set et après d'armes
pranger 7 mai dans l'autre variante le
pion à vii a été éliminé d'abord et en
prenant le 7e fait échec
donc on gagne du temps par rapport à la
variante que l'on voit ici et c'est pas
la même donc là bon ça menace quand même
dans le premier set
bon d'un premier set où cavaliers prend
pas mal aussi
c'est même ça a l'air très bien mais bon
on a donné fou pour d'options et au roi
qui est faible certes certes certes
certes mais ce qu'on pas prévu les
n'aurait sans doute les blancs
c'est la suite regardez ce que nous fait
here in a truck pas de détails boum
cavale et des trois échecs à ça fait mal
ça c'était pas prévu qu'à elle et des
trois échecs pourquoi c'est un sacrifice
de cavaillé on va dire oui oui c'est un
sacrifice en fait c'est un pseudo
sacrifices
voilà c'est un pseudo sacrifices que les
blancs sont bien obligés d'accepter
alors pas sur ce que bart si les blancs
font un coup comme dame roy paci si les
blancs funk ou comme roi des deux ça a
pas l'air très très bon puisque up
regardez on va des deux essayons de voir
ce qui se passe ici mais simplement
regarder la dame vient en f2 échec au
roi
alors si le roi apprend le cavalier
seimat échec laurent et matelas d'accord
tout est protégé
voilà c'est maintenant donc ces
chaussées c'est pas une bonne idée donc
dames et deux on peut pas prendre le
cavalier avec le roi donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait on est obligé de faire
car lieu demain voilà il faut il faut
faire cavalier 2 c'est la seule la seule
possibilité est là simplement les noirs
peut me faire revient toujours pas de
menace ici il n'y a pas de menace c'est
ça le problème
vous n'avez pas de menace de ce côté là
pas de vraie menace là se faire un petit
échec en uf6 mais il n'y a pas de
conséquence on viande 17 d'emprunt f7
tour 7 lato de la dame est attaqué et
l'attaquent ici continue donc là on a le
temps tranquillement de faire caler
prendre b2 calais prend b2 c'est pénible
parce que c'est pas tellement qu'on a
pris un pion c'est qu'on va pouvoir
jouer qu'à valises ses quatre échecs
on peut aussi le 2e cavaliers peuvent
venir en d4 rajoutant de la pression sur
eux deux voyez donc en fait c'est la
tâche noire qui est plus forte que la
tête blanche ici dans cette position
donc c'est l'horreur donc c'est
l'horreur donc sur calais detroit il
faut prendre mais là c'est la mauvaise
mauvaise nouvelle puisque l'on à damas
trois échecs roi des huns wife 1 c'est
la même chose
échec en c1 dames 3 échecs crois bien
dam des trois échecs en c1 c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle je vous rappelle que les
sofia les blancs il lui fallait gagner
la partie
donc là encore une fois bien que le fait
qu'on soit en match c'est pas pareil que
de jouer une partie sèche bon le
résultat ça peut être nulle victoire
gains bon là le résultat chercher il est
connu d'avancé
il faut il faut gagner absolument avec
les blancs ne peut pas se permettre de
faire nul d'un métro échec
et voilà crois bien et répétition des
coups donc nul
est ce que sophie aurait pu faire
quelque chose bien sûr d'un échec
on peut essayer de faire
roy f1 par exemple qu'est ce qui se
passe sur sur wife essayons de voir sa
f1 à ce cas là les noirs peuvent jouer
un peu n'importe quoi tout est bon de
toute façon par exemple d'un f4
voilà trente points f4 et on va prendre
5 puisque le cahier c6 protège et à
c'est fini les les blancs ont perdu tout
ou jeu de ce côté là quoi on peut même
prendre 5 du cavalier cavaliers qui
protégeait vii
surtout que le roi blanc sera toujours
sur la menace d' échec supplémentaire
et si on défend du cavalier c'est
possible elle simplement les noirs
continuent leur jeu par fou 17
et puis on va tour j'ai vite attaqué
alors on va mettre les tours sur les
colonies six essais les noirs qu'on
n'attaque pas les blancs voilà donc
c'est l'horreur malheureusement sophie
est obligé est quasiment de prendre là
nul donc elle s'est lancée a donc le
moment clé ici en fait dans cette partie
c'est probablement bon il fallait
qu'elle gagne alors elle a tenté le coup
bon est ce que c'était vraiment
la meilleure solution c'est facile à
dire après bien sûr elle a fait faux
prince est ici dans cette position-là l
attente est fou prend 1,7 aurait pu
marcher contre d'autres joueurs qui
green a crush mais face à irina crush ça
marche pas voilà donc à l'orée du
peut-être essayer de jeu c'est pas de
jouer est ce qu'on peut jouer la
variante autrement où il sans doute
alors est plus fou prend 1,7
on va prendre un set peut-être ici faire
cavalier cheikh roi bouge et pas joui
d'un match qui a tout de suite mais par
exemple raroc d'abord grand roque
d'abord voilà gras rock d'abord et puis
peut-être menace sa menace d'un match 4
comme le roi est engagé 8 on ne peut pas
jouer on a affalé noir vont quand même
être obligé de subir d'un match 4 et
peut-être que là il ya une attaque
intéressante à faire peut-être
voilà en tout cas bon ce qu'elle a
choisi n'a pas n'a pas fonctionné donc
nulle part et pétition ici et donc
voila apres dam des trois ans ici voilà
c'est nulle part répétition donc sophie
millet ne fait que nul dans cette partie
et donc elle le perd le match
puisqu'elle avait perdu la première
voilà championnat du monde terminée pour
pour sophie malheureusement bon c'est
dommage on aurait mis la voir jouer deux
ou trois tours de plus pourquoi pas mais
ça sera peut-être pour une prochaine
fois il nous reste donc maintenant à
suivre marie sebag comme française en
16e de finale pour la suite des
évènements sur des gones ltv merci de
m'avoir suivi et à la prochaine
au revoir